I felt like the game they showed to me
in that first CGI scene was going to be
somewhat realistic to what the actual
game was going to be and the two art
styles weren't anywhere close to each
other so it's interesting I I I disagree
but I but to your point a lot of people
have said what you said right and they
need to see more from it you know me I
like the thing with the sword the other
hand with the spellcasting you know the
different classes and stuff like that to
me I know the story is going to be great
I'm not really worried about um about
but I will say
the thing that I am worried about is I
didn't like if you read those paragraphs
everybody else was like uh you know
gameplay Indiana Jones gameplay about
gameplay Aura hellblade sound like we're
GNA go behind the scenes with the studio
and talk about you know it felt like
we're going to be there in niceland or
something like I didn't get the sense
that like we we're going to get game
plan I'm not trying to be hard on them